emergency officials are keeping a close
eye on a massive sinkhole which
swallowed two homes on Friday and could
still be expanding it happened in the
city of land o lakes florida about 20
miles north of Tampa Tony Duke opal has
the story
the sinkhole formed just after 7:30 a.m.
on Friday morning under a boat parked on
the street about an hour later it
started taking the first house we were
able to see suction coming in where it
foam from the top was being pulled under
the ground and at that point large
trunks to the ground were actually
caving in the land continued to cave and
by 9:30 it had taken down part of a
neighboring home right now we're looking
at a proximally 200 foot wide sinkhole
and the geology reports from the last
time they mediated this particular
sinkhole estimated the depth of 50 feet
Jose Rodriguez told CBS station WTSP in
Tampa he left for work before the earth
collapse under his house and when you
come back and you see your house also
starting to crumble wood
I can describe that at least we got to
everyone out and the family and the dogs
in all our papers officials caution that
the sinkhole is still growing and could
expand into lakes axon about 200 feet
away it reaches the lake we're gonna
have some serious problems happen
because that's gonna contaminate the
cleanest lake in the neighborhood Pasco
County Public Safety official Kevin
Guthrie says they've already seen damage
to septic tanks we believe this is now
if you will a hazmat incident we have
household chemicals and household items
inside the water as many as 11
neighboring homes have been evacuated
and officials still don't know how big
the hole will grow unfortunately we
can't give clear answers because this is
mother nature and we don't know what
direction this sinkhole is going to go
we don't know if it makes another sharp
direction for CBS this morning Saturday
22 Koval New York